- When we started getting all that money
funneling into the country
after the end of World War II
and the Social Democrats were all like,
"Look at us, how good
socialism is working."
- Yes.
- It had nothing
to do with them.
In fact their policies,
big government policies,
wasted all that money and you know
in the 1990s we actually had to devaluate
our currency against the dollar.
30% of everything was lost
because the welfare state they'd built up.
(gentle music)
- This is "The Rubin Report"
and I'm once again, Dave Rubin.
Here's a friendly reminder
to subscribe to our channel
by clicking that pesky bell
and turning on notifications
so that you might, just
might, see our videos
and more importantly, joining me today
are two Swedish podcast superstars
and free speech activists.
In no order, Aron Flam and Henrik Jonsson.
Welcome to the Rubin Report.
- Thank you for having us.
- I am glad to have you guys.
We have sat down before.
- Yes, couple of years ago.
- A couple of years ago.
Before I do anything else,
did I give proper Swedish
pronunciation of the names there?
That was a very American version, do you--
- 10 out of 10.
- Yeah?
- I'm fine with however you say my name.
- Henrik--
- I said--
- Henrik Jonsson, Jonsson.
- Right, so I purposely did that.
So I said, so if you were saying Aron Flam
in perfect Swedish, how would you say it?
- Aron Flam.
- Okay, there we go.
- And I said Henrik Jonsson,
but I knew it was a
little more off with you.
- Yeah, Henrik Jonsson.
That's the way you say it in Swedish--
- Henrik Jonsson.
- Jonsson.
But you know, I lived
in London for 10 years
so I almost changed my name to Johnson
because the nightmare of explaining
this bizarre pronunciation just, yeah--
- And also, the O with
two dots on top of it.
- There's the O with the two dots
and I knew that they J was
really a Y in our world.
But I wanted you to say it first
so it sounded a little smoother.
Anyway, I'm thrilled
to have you guys here.
I'll preface all of this by saying
something that I told you
guys earlier in the week
when I did both of your podcasts
which is that bizarrely, almost impossibly
our fifth most-watched
country for this show,
"The Rubin Report" is Sweden.
So it's the United States first
and then usually Canada and
the UK battle out two and three
and then Australia is
four and then Sweden.
- Even though we only
have 10 million people.
- I have half the population of Sweden
in this room right now.
(Henrik laughs)
- Yes. (laughs)
- And some how,
whatever it is that
we're talking about here
related to free speech and the rest of it
has really hit a nerve in Sweden.
I also think it's partly
because I had you on
and that show really just exploded.
I've since done a couple shows
in Sweden with Jordan Peterson.
So before we do anything else
and I'll got to you first,
just tell my audience a
little bit about yourself,
tell me a little bit about yourself
and what you do and all that good stuff.
And then we'll recap with you
and then we'll take it from there.
- Well my background,
I'm really a businessman.
I'm an IT entrepreneur.
I built a number of
companies over the years.
But about two years ago I recorded
a small YouTube video, well
actually a Facebook video
on my phone where I, out of spite,
I was irritated with the journalistics,
journalist establishment's incapacity
of correctly describing
the difference between
dividends and profit in a private company
because we had this big debate
about how we didn't want
commercial companies
in the healthcare sector.
So I made a video where I say,
"Okay listen guys, if
you wanna talk about this
"you need to understand
the difference between
"those two different things
and I'm gonna tell y'all."
So I posted it on Facebook.
Morning after I woke up,
my mailbox was overflowing.
I had so many people just going, "Wow,
"you're so good at explaining this stuff.
"Nobody ever talks about this."
And then I started making videos.
Now I runt the largest politically-minded
YouTube channel in Sweden.
- Should I ask what level of hate you got
just by putting out a
video about dividends
(Henrik laughs)
and health insurance
in the market?
- Well, you know that was
a sort of neutral video
because it was on taxation.
But let's put it this way--
- Taxation often is not neutral,
at least in this country.
Oh and maybe it's a little more neutral
for you guys because
you've been numbed into it
or something like that.
- Well, taxation is like are for us.
- Right, (laughs) exactly.
(Henrik laughs)
But did you get a lotta hate?
Or I guess you didn't?
- Initially very little
because the situation we have back home
is like the left does
not follow people like me
because I'm, you know, I
have a business background.
They think, "Well, he's a capitalist pig
"so let's not listen to this guy."
- Yeah.
- But as my channel grew
and now I have about
600,000 people a month
watching my videos, which is more
than most of the national newspapers have
so then I become a problem.
So now I'm getting quite a bit of flac
just, you know, just being on your show
is probably gonna push
a few people's buttons.
- We're gonna quadruple your flac
(Henrik laughs)
by the end of today.
Aron I, obviously I know a
little more about your story.
But for the people that
did not see our first into.
- Well, as they should know
because they should have
watched every episode
of your show--
- I assume most of them have.
- I'm a Swedish comedian
and then after a while
I realized I can't do my jokes any more,
my beautiful constructed
child pornography jokes.
(Dave laughs)
- And then I had to,
well we don't exactly have
free speech in Sweden.
We got it in '94 from the EU.
That's sort of, eh,
but I would like to have some in Sweden.
So I've been working at
that since last we met
and since we met last I've been doing
very little comedy, although I have
done some comedy because--
- Yeah, you did some stand up
in L.A. just a couple days ago.
- Yes, at the L.A. Improv
and it went quite well.
They loved my abortion jokes
and since last we met,
because at the point
when we met I wanted
to find the route cause
of the craziness that is going on
in the Western world right now.
And you've written a book about it
and I just finished and
published my book about it.
Unfortunately in Swedish, but I'll get you
an English version.
- I want the English version
because not only do I not speak Swedish
but your book, oh we shoulda
had it on the table here.
I'll have my guys grab it.
It's about how many pages?
Almost 500 pages, right?
And this thing is dense.
I mean, you could if you
whacked somebody with this thing
it's like a brick.
- Yes, I want--
- You can take out--
- I want everything I do
to be able to be used in multiple ways.
(Dave laughs)
But no, it's called,
"This is a Swedish Tiger"
and basically it's,
I got proof that the
socialists and the Islamists
have pretty much been working together
since the end of World War II
and the socialists didn't turn in '43
but they were on Hitler's
side until the end.
And after the war they sort of
swept that under the carpet,
found alliances, because the Islamists
or what turned, morphed
into the Islamists,
were on Hitler's side as well
and they continued that alliance.
And I think we're seeing the end point
of that cooperation now.
- [Dave] So it's a comedy?
- Well, it's a
very dark comedy.
(Dave laughs)
- Yeah exactly.
Like almost everything these days.
So you start doing video pod,
did you start doing video first?
- Video right away.
- All on video.
So you start doing the video
and just by talking about these things
my sense from what's going on in Sweden
is that there's just a lot of
people due to cultural reasons
that hopefully you guys can explain,
just don't really say what
they're thinking enough.
- Yes.
- And then it makes guys
like you very unique.
A comedian, it's one thing to be doing it
but a guy from a business background.
Were you shocked--
- Yes.
- At what was happening?
- Yes I was.
- Yeah.
- Listen, I think
part of the reason that your show
is popular in Sweden is our nation
is like the canary in the coal mine
and people are so penned up
because we have a highly,
like a fiercely egalitarian culture.
It's very conformist, so
it's incredibly threatening
to break the mold, but
there's this pent up need of
you know, seriously engaging
in open conversation
about a lot of issues that are,
well they put the lid on those.
And I think that's what
you're picking up on
when you went there.
And I think that is why once
I started making my videos
it just exploded, because
there were so many people,
"Wow, how do you dare say these things?"
- What were the first
couple type o' things
that you were talking about?
- Well, here's where Aron
and I kind of connect
because I wanted to debunk the idea that
the Social Democratic rule
which has been running Sweden
for the better part of
the last hundred years,
they took credit for the
financial miracle that we had.
Basically, Sweden rose from a rather poor
agrarian economy into the per capita
wealthiest country on Earth
over a couple of decades.
But that was mainly due,
and if you ask economists
they will know this, but
nobody speaks about it,
the reason that happened was because
we did not take a stand
against the Nazis in the war.
So we actually sold them
iron ore and granite
and after the war we were also
the only intact manufacturing,
industrialized manufacturing
nation in Europe
so we exported everything to everyone
and that's how we became rich.
- So you were acting like capitalists
sort of on the DL, on the down low,
but in effect--
- I'd say no (murmurs) the worst brand
of crony capitalism I would say.
- Yeah, what about you?
You were doing stand up first
but what were the issues first
that you were talking about
that you realized
shouldn't be talked about?
- Well--
- Or that people didn't
want you to talk about?
- I as a comedian
I know what cultural taboos we have
so I just made a list and, you know,
started doing jokes on
every cultural taboo
because that was my job.
So I went through, you
know, the usual shock thing
you can always do a pedophilia joke
because, you know, or a fisting joke.
It's funny.
(participants laugh)
But then I started drugs--
- Aron--
- and mariajuana--
- This is a family show.
(Aron laughs)
- And then I went to mariajuana
but I'd never experienced as much hate
as when I started my
campaign to crush socialism.
Because in their minds that's just
the most taboo thing you could ever say.
That's the entire system, you know?
You're basically shitting where you eat.
- So when you say you don't
have free speech in Sweden,
what does that actually mean as--
- Well, you are free to
say whatever you want
as long a no one takes
offense or gets insulted.
- Because what's gonna happen
if someone takes offense or gets insulted?
'Coz we're now, we seem--
- Because--
- to be importing this idea.
- Yes, because then
their feelings are hurt.
If you want to have a
socialist welfare state,
everyone has to be like cogs in the wheel
so that's why you need
conformism and collectivism
and a culture of silence.
And that is why they get so annoyed
when he speaks out, because he's breaking
the culture of silence.
And cultures of silence are
about maintaining the real
because as long as
everyone has the same lie
then that's reality.
But if someone says, "Wait a minute,
"this might not be exactly the case."
Like for instance, Henrik got burglarized
in Malmo where he lives.
I don't know if he told you
that story?
- Yes, I do wanna
talk about that.
- Yeah.
And when he talks about that
he breaks the culture of silence
that Sweden is peaceful, it is ordered,
everything works, no one
needs a gun for self defense
because the police or the state
will take care of everything.
And remarkably enough, that's the reason
why my book, by the way, is called,
"This is a Swedish Tiger"
because tiger in Swedish
means both the apex predator and shut up.
- Huh.
- So during the
Second World War there
was a campaign in Sweden
launched by the government that said,
"Be a Swedish tiger" which means
be silent but deadly.
- It's very clever and very
Orwellian campaign.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That is extremely Orwellian.
- I'd like to add two
things what you just said,
I mean formally you're allowed to say
anything you want in Sweden.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But the consequences
of doing so can be very, very severe
and people will hate you and they will
sometimes go after your employer.
They will try to make it
impossible for you to work.
So it is a culture of silence
and it's very aggressive,
but we never speak of it.
The other thing--
- (laughs) Which is
what a culture of silence is.
(Henrik laughs)
(Dave murmurs)
Don't mention the
culture of silence.
(Henrik laughs)
- Yeah, the but wasn't necessary there.
Also we are doing this,
so you know. (laughs)
- But the second thing
that I think is important
to mention there, is like
the establishment media of
Sweden, sort of you know,
the news organizations and so forth
they have been losing
a lot of their revenue
to the digital tech giants
like Google and Facebook
and so forth and are
very unhappy about that.
So they've been pushing the government
to intervene with what they're doing
under the guise of, "Well, you know,
"it's promoting extremism or whatever.
"People are writing
nasty things on Facebook"
and they pushed it all the
way to the top government
so the Minister of Justice
actually had a meeting
with Google and Facebook, and this is,
you can read this in the papers.
I can send you links for this.
Where he actually told
them, "Well of course
"there's freedom of speech and it's great
"that you're private companies
"and private companies
make their own decisions."
Isn't that sort of putting
like a virtual gun--
- Yeah yeah.
- Against your back.
- You're private for now.
- "We think you should clean up
"some of the stuff on your platforms
"otherwise we might have to
move forward with regulation."
Now I wouldn't wanna be the
President of Facebook Sweden
having to answer to an American CEO
you know, tell them that, "I'm the guy
"that made 'em regulate our company."
- So what type of slurs have
been thrown at you guys?
'Cause that seems to be
what it boils down to.
You haven't been dragged
off to jail, right?
So when we talk about free speech it's not
they haven't jailed you yet.
But what type of slurs
are they throwing at you
to make sure that it perhaps hampers
some of your businesses?
Or hampers your ability to
perform at the clubs or--
- Well five or six days
ago they called us whores.
- Venmo whores.
- Venmo whores, who's they in this case?
- Well that would be,
this was actually a text
written by a rather famous
establishment journalist
in one of the biggest national papers.
- Right.
- Who had a big issue--
- So in effect he works
for a state-run paper
but because--
- No, no, here's the thing.
- Yeah.
- So they call these papers
and media outlets free media.
- Right.
- But they're all on the
take, as you would call it.
Or subsidized as we
would call it. (laughs)
- This guy was actually on Swedish radio
so I have the recording
downloaded where he--
- Yeah, that's state radio actually, yeah.
- That's state, yeah.
- So okay, so--
- But that--
- So someone on state radio,
he's funded by the state to
get his message out there,
called you guys, independent people,
putting stuff up on YouTube--
- He likened us to prostitutes.
- You guys are venmo whore.
- Yeah.
- This is grifter, right?
This is the one that gets thrown at us
in America all the time.
- Right.
If you tried it, you know?
It's like, "If I was grifting
"I would be doing the other thing" right?
What would be--
- Right.
- If we were grifters what would be
the easiest thing to do?
- Work for MPR? (laughs)
- (laughs) Exactly,
work for MPR, but into socialism,
buy into intersectionality.
- Yeah, and that's what they
want from you.
- What a great great grift.
Yeah.
- They want to turn you
into us.
- Yeah. Now these--
- As I told you last time.
- Okay.
- We want you to assimilate.
- Okay, so that's exactly
where I wanted to go with this
because if you listen to
our socialist democrats
or democratic socialists,
or whatever the hell they are these days.
I keep saying they're gonna drop
the democrat part soon enough,
what they always say is, "We
should be more like Sweden."
AOC says this, Bernie says this.
I doubt that AOC has ever been to Sweden.
Perhaps Bernie has been to Sweden.
But they say the Nordic countries usually
but it's specifically, "We
should be more like Sweden."
Now you guys have 10 million people,
we have 350 million people.
We have people from every walk of life,
from every corner of the Earth.
You guys mainly were a homogenous society
until the last couple o' years.
There's all sorts of
reasons that that analogy
doesn't quite make sense.
But when you hear that, "America should be
"more like Sweden" what does that--
- Nothing pushes my buttons
(Dave laughs)
then when I hear stuff
like that, you know?
This comes out of the mouth
of what, Bernie Sanders
or Elizabeth Warren?
Let's clear this up once and for all.
Sweden was never a socialist country
in the sense that the Eastern block was,
you know, Soviet Union and so forth.
When Sweden became wealthy,
this was during the last part of the 1800s
we had a bunch of
laissez-faire reforms done.
So that's when we started
a transformation to industrialize.
We were actually quite late to the game.
It was these, you know,
free market reforms.
- When you got the government out
laissez-faire--
- Yes.
- Suddenly the economy
starts booming, okay.
- Johan August Gripenstedt
is the name of the guy
that was very forward-thinking
that made these reforms possible
and then things started
getting better after that.
The other thing you need to remember
is that when we started
getting all that money
funneling into the country
after the end of World War II
and the Social Democrats
were all like, "Look at us.
"How good socialism is working."
- Yes.
- And it had nothing
to do with them.
In fact, their policies,
big government policies,
wasted all that money and you know,
in the 1990s we actually had
to devaluate our currency
against the dollar.
30% of everything was lost
because of the welfare state
they built up.
So if you hear Bernie Sanders or Warren
say stuff like, "We need
to be more like Sweden"
well, the part they're missing
is that what was good about Sweden
was free-market oriented.
What was bad about Sweden, we turned out
into a decent country
in spite of socialism,
not because of.
- Can you add to that?
That was a pretty--
- I can confirm--
- concise explanation.
- that is true.
and you can look it up, it's factual, yes.
- Yeah, so when you guys hear that
and doing what you're
doing, I mean as you said,
it just makes your head spin sort of.
You feel like you're gonna smack somebody.
- Well I love my job.
(Dave chuckles)
I really do.
Because I get to piss people off
and I believe what Larry David once said
that "If you have the
opportunity to annoy someone
"you should take it." (laughs)
- Yeah. (laughs)
- Well you are doing that.
- Yeah you're doing just fine there.
But do you think part of the issue here
is that the exterior of
Sweden looks a certain way.
So, for example I had two
trips to Sweden, to Stockholm,
and I was only in Stockholm
so what I'm seeing
is a very snapshot version.
But just from walking around Stockholm
or maybe what we see in the media if,
or in the movies if they
show someone from Sweden
they're always very tall,
they look very good.
You know, they're blonde like you
and they're in nice jackets.
And what I notice from
walking around Stockholm
was it looked like everyone bought
their clothes that morning.
Everyone looked fantastic.
(Henrik laughs)
Everything was clean,
the streets were clean,
all these things.
Now I get it, it's a very small
little micro version of this
but is that part of the problem,
that the veneer of this
somehow is still selling well?
Or something like that
outside of your borders?
- Absolutely, I think it's
a sort of a Potemkin village
if you know what that is?
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's a backdrop and behind it,
well, it reminds me of Hollywood that way.
- Yeah, you're in the right town.
- Yeah, yeah, if you look
at it in front it looks good
but if you look behind the curtain you,
but you don't hide your homeless.
We would hide them.
- Yeah.
- Now we can't afford
to hide them any more.
- Well we can't hide them any more
because you're here in California
where they're pretty much everywhere.
- They are, I have noticed.
- Yeah.
- No, but I think just
like not speaking out
against things you might
see as wrong or incorrect,
it is very important that
everything looks good
if you are to have a culture of silence
and a quasi-socialist state.
- How are you guys able to gauge
how much effect you're actually having
on the the average Swede?
- I'd say judging by the
reactions we're getting
from our enemies (chuckles)
(Aron laughs)
things are going very well.
- Yeah.
- They get very upset, you know?
Funnily enough, the extreme left people
they usually do not touch me.
It is the social liberals
who are, you know,
supposed to be center-right.
- Can you explain a little bit
what the differentiation there is
for an American perspective?
'Cause I think Americans hear that,
the social liberals and the far left.
That sounds sort of like the same thing.
- Of course, yes.
Liberal here means a lefty
whereas in Europe the word liberal
is moving that direction
in Europe as well,
but it still means more like the classical
Austrian liberalism.
- Yeah, yeah.
I'm a European liberal.
- Yeah.
- Right, something like that.
- Perfect, me too.
I would use the word fiscally conservative
but socially liberal to describe myself.
So that's where most of
the attacks are coming from
on my end, you know?
From journalist, you
know people of platform,
establishment media platforms.
They will be very upset and they will find
a single word that they
don't like in a sentence,
pull it out and start a
tweet storm, you know?
They will tell you things like,
"You're dangerous, you're
populistic, alarmist.
"You're not taking responsibility
for what kind of people
"you take on to your show."
And you know, going back to this thing
with the canary in the coal
mine, this is the thing
because what all of these
people have been doing
is working so very hard
at guiding the population
to the correct moral standpoint
at the end of whatever they produce.
And you don't do that, you
bring somebody else on the show
and say, "Okay, this is a
completely different perspective
"and I'm not going to attack you.
"I don't wanna fight you.
"I want to explore your idea
"and just see what I make of it."
They hate it.
They do not want it.
- Yeah, is there anyone politically
that is echoing some of your sentiments
about what's happening in Sweden?
- Well, Hanif Bali does
the job from time to time
when his party doesn't
try to reign him in.
- Which party is he part of?
- He's part of the Moderate Party
which--
- Which is right wing.
That would be, by American standards
that would be like--
- Ultra leftists.
(Henrik murmurs)
- I know, right?
(Aron laughs)
Well, like what type of
policies would they have?
Just 'cause I'm trying to get a map.
- Lower taxes, more
personal responsibility
and individual choice.
They're trying to get it in there but--
- So he'd basically be a
conservative or libertarian?
- Light version of the conservative.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Socially, socially--
- I think they call themselves
liberal conservatives.
- Liberal conservatives.
- Yes.
- That sort of, that
jives with me I suppose.
So I told you guys that
when I was in Stockholm
for the two shows with Jordan Peterson
and I saw you there, that
they really stuck out.
Well first off I was
particularly excited about them
because I knew that this small country
was my fifth most-watched country
and I was like, "What the
hell's goin' on here?"
So I sorta, and Jordan also knew
that a huge percentage of
his viewership was from there
so we both sorta had that date,
that first Stockholm date in our minds
that something special's happening.
The shows were incredible.
The first show sold out
literally in a minute
which is why we added the second show.
The audiences were phenomenal,
correct me if I'm wrong.
- You were so popular
there was a black market
trading in tickets to your shows.
- I would like to say that it was Jordan
that was very popular,
(Henrik laughs)
so just for the record.
But (claps hands) the
thing that truly struck me
was that after the show we
would do our meet and greets
and Jordan would meet with
hundreds of people mind.
We would just quickly sell them basically
right before the show so I'd usually get
you know, 30 or 40 people
'cause we have do it very quick.
But at the two Stockholm shows we had
about 80 or 100 people.
We jammed all of these
people into a small room.
We're sitting there and it felt
like something memorable to me.
It felt like everyone in that room--
- They had prepared questions for you.
- Everyone in that--
- Not Jordan,
they had prepared for you.
- Everyone in that room
had something written down
or something on their phone
or something they wanted to hand to me
or a book that I should
read or a story or something
and it was so moving to me,
that I think I said to you,
"Is there a bar around here we can go to?"
And we took everybody and we went to a bar
and we hung out for hours and met some--
- Until they closed.
- Until they closed, they kicked us out
and I met some of the
Swedish intellectuals
that you guys hang out
with, all these people.
Anyway, I'm not even
asking a question here,
suffice to say that it was so
obvious to me that something
is going on there.
- Well you could--
- It was truly moving.
- Apart from having a
disproportionate amount of viewers
for such a small country, of your show
and Jordan's videos,
well you caused quite a splash.
- Oh, (laughs) can you
say what happened, yeah?
- Our Minister of Foreign Affairs
went out publicly and
said, "Jordan Peterson
"is a bug and should crawl back
"under the rock he came from."
- Yes, which I was able to quote her
at the beginning of the show
and it got quite a laugh.
(Henrik laughs)
Everyone basically screamed
the end of the joke
before I said it.
(Henrik laughs)
- Well yes, she just retired thank god.
- You can't buy PR like that.
- Yeah, but whadda you
make of that sorta thing?
So when you know the ideas
that Jordan sets forth?
- So let me just explain.
Our Minister of Foreign
Affairs, she goes to Iran.
She goes to all these places
and does business, as one should,
with dictators or whatever, or not.
So she meets truly horrible
people in her work.
- Do you mean even worse
than Jordan Peterson?
- And that's what's so funny.
(Henrik laughs)
I mean, this is just a Canadian
professor of psychology
who tells people to make their beds
in the morning. (laughs)
(Dave laughs)
And she's never voiced anything negative
about the Iranian regime, or yeah.
So it's quite...
- You know it's funny, or not funny
I suppose depressing at a certain level
that she said that after our first show.
So then I think we had a day or two away.
I think maybe we were in
Copenhagen or somewhere else
and I remember thinking
when we were coming back
that, you know, we're going
through security again,
we're going through the border again,
and I remember thinking,
we just saw this story.
I think we saw it on the plane
what the Foreign Minister said
and I thought, "Why wouldn't
they stop us at the border
"or harass him or whatever?"
Now they didn't, but that sorta thing.
It's like we can sorta joke about it now
and it sounds so ridiculous
but there is another human element to it
that is pretty scary.
- But you came in
and just coming in is
breaking a culture of silence.
So they have to do something.
They have to tell their listeners,
"Don't listen to these guys.
"They are here to destroy us" you know?
- And I mean the story you're telling
about how all these people
had written down questions for you,
to me that's actually,
it's a beautiful thing
that it almost brings tears to my eyes.
- Oh, it literally almost brought tears
to my eyes that night.
- Because, you know,
I get all these emails
from young guys who want to
begin exploring their lives
and they are thirsty for, you know,
an open discussion and the
fact that Margot Wallstrom,
you know the minister that told Jordan
"To crawl under a rock", that
is like the perfect example
of the culture of silence that we have.
Because the fact that he just
showed up in Sweden, you know?
They had to make a stand
that this is, "What this man
"is saying is not part of the narrative
"that we want here."
- Yes.
- Can you talk about how this is related
to sort of how men are treated
or at least talked about in Sweden?
Because you guys have
the first, supposedly,
self-proclaimed feminist
government, right?
- Yes.
- That's what even though--
- As you can tell when they visited Iran
they all wore niqabs.
(Dave laughs)
So very feminist indeed.
- Yeah, very feminist indeed.
But the reason I mention that is
because, as I said earlier,
I did both of your podcasts
which we'll link to below
because I want people
to see you guys as hosts.
But I mentioned the story to both of you
of how the day of the Stockholm
shows it was cold out,
I wanted to get a hat and I went into H&M
which is your, is that your great,
well H&M--
- It's like Gap here.
- Ikea are your greatest exports.
And I went into H&M and I
was on line to buy the hat
and the guy in front of me, young guy,
probably 20, 21 years
old says to the cashier,
"This is the first suit I've ever bought."
He was speaking in English,
"The first suit I've ever bought
"and I'm going to see this
Jordan Peterson show tonight."
And then the cashier
says, "I'm going to see
"the Jordan Peterson show tonight."
So I tapped the guy on the shoulder,
I turned around and
said, "I'm going to see
"the Jordan Peterson show"
and he knew who I was.
And I just thought it was
such an incredible moment,
like this young kid who literally
was buying the first suit of his life to,
as you just said, listen to a
Canadian psychology professor
tell him to sit up straight
with his shoulders back.
So can you talk a little
bit about what's happening
with either young people or men or both
or some combination of that?
- Well we've had a,
there's a problem with language
because what I think they're
trying to do in Sweden,
have been trying for my entire life
is they're trying to
accomplish gender equity.
And that's not the same thing
as equality of the sexes, right?
- 'Cause you guys have
equality of the sexes
in many senses, right?
- That depends on what
you mean with equality.
- What's your--
- Men and women have
the same opportunities.
In some cases women even
have more opportunities
economically when it comes to subsidies
for being pregnant, for
instance, or taking--
- The results of the free--
- maternity leave.
- The results of the free choices
that women make are though
considered a problem--
- Yes.
- Right, so this is the,
this is the interesting, wait
but just to be clear though
'cause what part of what I said did--
- No, no, no, no.
But when you go for gender equity
what you want is, well
you want a facade, right?
You want 50/50%.
- Yeah.
- 50% here and 50% there
men and women.
It doesn't matter if they're competent,
if they want to work there.
And we have government
bodies regulating this
and trying to, and we do this
from kindergarten and upwards.
We encourage the girls
to take up more space
and be less like girls,
and we encourage the boys
to close inwards and not
take up as much space.
So basically what they're trying to do
is they're trying to make these kids
go against their biology or
whatever they feel is right
because they want it to look perfect.
- So to be clear it's not just--
- And equal or equitous.
- It's not just, right.
It's not just you know,
"You should act this way"
but it ends up working
into what jobs they choose
because Jordan mentioned
this several times there
and a lotta people talk about this
that because you guys have
had equality for so long
meaning you could do whatever you want
as a man or a women,
it turned out that yes,
women tend to be nurses more,
and men turned out to be engineers more
because women generally are
more interested in people
and men happen to be more
interested in things.
That's just the nature of reality.
But I think--
- The gender paradox.
- I think this is what
you were getting to,
the social justice word is
don't like that experiment.
They don't like the experiment of freedom.
- Jordan was on a talk show in Sweden
where he was addressing this very topic
and he basically said, "Well you know,
"science supports that
this is the way it happens
"in a free country where
people can choose."
And we had one of the
top-level politicians
there and she was, "Well
I don't agree with that."
And you know I was just,
(Dave laughs)
I actually made an episode
on my show about that
because I'm like, "This man
just said 'Science says this.'
"'I don't agree with it.'"
Okay, so what are we now, mystics?
- So what you're saying is--
- Well we are, yeah.
- Yeah, so that thing though,
the politician says that,
"I don't agree with it.
"I don't agree with what science says,
"I don't agree with what biology says."
We all know that men
and women are different
it doesn't make either
sex better than the other
it's just an is.
- No.
- But when you hear
that response you think
most people just swallow that and take it?
- I think most people
do that because we're
a fiercely egalitarian,
very conformist people.
So they have been trained for very long
to just accept that form of communication.
Now we have, you know, a government body
the Ministry of Equality,
and I mean just the name
sounds so totalitarian I
can't, you know it's like--
- "Nineteen Eighty-Four" event.
- Totally, and they have the authority
to look at all companies and
other governmental bodies
to achieve the 50/50.
- Kindergartens, schools,
universities, everything.
Everything has to be gender mainstreamed.
- And is all run by women. (laughs)
There are only women working at the--
- So right, so when you do this then
as a private businessman,
how does that affect you?
- You know, funny thing is like
when my YouTube channel started taking off
my business partner he was
like, "Okay, what's happening,
"what's going on?
"This might actually hurt
our business interests."
And I said, "Well you
know, if we start seeing
"some disasters happening
because of what I'm saying online
"we'll have a conversation
and say, 'Okay.'"
And so we tried it for a while,
turns out business is booming
because now people are finding me
just because they see
my videos and, "I wanna
"work with your company."
So even though we have
all these enemies now,
those are people I wouldn't
wanna work with anyway. (chuckles)
- Right, but what about
on the hiring side though?
I mean, when you're actually hiring people
do you have to look at those
immutable characteristics
to figure out who you're gonna hire?
- Well I don't handle the
recruiting any more personally
so I've kind of removed myself,
my face, from that a bit.
I don't think it's much of a problem
because Sweden has a general problem
when it comes to
recruiting talented people,
we don't have enough of them.
We have a lot of people that are going,
you know, subsidies and various
government programs, loads.
But I'm in IT recruiting
very smart IT professionals.
That's generally very difficult.
Although, I find I have
quite a few of them,
you know, these software guys
that are quite libertarian.
So no, I don't see it as
a great problem, you know?
Here's another thing I'd like to mention,
you're not allowed to ask
people anything you want
when you hire them in Sweden.
So when I first started out my company
I would ask people, "Are you in any unions
"because I don't want any
unionized people in my companies."
And then my HR eventually,
"You gotta stop saying
"that Henrik, it's illegal.
"You cannot ask them
if they're unionized."
So now we have a text in when we recruit
which is kind of like, "Are you a very
"collectivistically-minded person?
"This might not be the place for you."
- Yeah geez, I mean this is happening
everywhere now, so nothing
sort of surprises.
- No, but I think
it does hurt kids because if you raise
entire generations of girls
telling them that they are beautiful
and weak and strong at the
same time and can do no wrong,
well you're turning them into
sexist fascists basically
and you're telling all the boys
that they are inherently evil,
and we've been doing
this for a long time now.
- So is that the part that's particularly
perverse about this?
You take a society, you make them equal.
Then at the same time because you know
that humans are gonna
have individual emotions
you keep telling the
males that they're evil
despite the fact that you in Sweden
have done more for equality
than virtually anybody.
So it's really like
it's just never enough,
because actually as you guys know
what they want is not really equality,
it's some sort of--
- No, no.
- Conformity is what they want.
- And I've been trying to tell them
that this would be as if
someone came out as gay
and you told them, "No,
suppress that" right?
Because that's what
you're telling the boys.
Like, "Oh, you feel the need the need
"to run around and play
football, suppress it."
- "You're a smart girl."
- And you're telling
the girls like, "You're playing
"with dolls, bad girl.
"Go out and play football."
- Now before the haters
get in here and say,
"Oh Aron Flam doesn't want
boys to play with Barbies"
you actually are perfectly okay if they--
- I never played football.
I was not the type.
(Dave laughs)
- And you had the
huge Barbie collection.
(Henrik laughs)
- Well.
- Which for a man
of your age is a bit much now.
- (laughs) I was into He-Man
and Star Wars figurines.
Or action--
- Action figures.
- Yes, you call them that to make them
sound more manly, but
they're basically dolls.
- I'll show you my collection
when we're outta here.
(Henrik laughs)
All right let's shift a bit
because you mentioned actually
that you lived and I
believe you're moving,
if I can say that--
- Yes.
In Malmo, now we here a lot about Malmo
on a certain side of the internet
where they report on a lot of bombings
and stabbings and all these weird things
coming outta Malmo.
Now we only hear of
this from sort of right,
what I would say are not just center right
but more right-leaning
things, outlets in America.
And then anyone that reports on them
says that they're racist
and they're bigoted
and the rest of it.
You live in Malmo, what happened in Malmo?
And just tell me a little bit
about the history of Malmo
before anything else.
- Malmo, it's in the deep south of Sweden.
So it's a port city and this is where
basically everyone that's coming to Sweden
by foot or by car, they
will enter across a bridge
and they come into Malmo
so we have a very large number of refugees
and so forth from the crisis of 2015.
And Malmo, it's always been
a rather poor city, you know?
They used to build big ships there
and then in the 1980s that all collapsed
and everyone was an alcoholic for a while.
Then it kind of became slightly better
but it's a loss-making city
and it's been run by
socialists for you know,
better part of the last hundred years.
Now over time, crime in Malmo
started to rise uncontrollably
and again, coming back to
the same topic all the time,
this concept of being quiet
about what is happening
because it's considered rude to mention
the fact that well, we
might have a drug war
going on in this city, and
that's what we have right now.
So people are working
very hard at putting out
different kind of representations,
statistical representations
saying, "everything is fine"
but you know, it's
getting harder and harder
for them to do that because everyone knows
that we did not use to have weekly bombs
going off in the city
center, for one thing.
And if I can, I'd like
to sort of tie this back
to a personal experience.
You mentioned that time
that I was burglarized
and what's really
interesting about that story
is not so much the fact
that I was burglarized
but rather the reaction
I got from the media
when I wrote about this
in the paper.
- And from the police
when you asked them, "What
can I do about this?"
So please, go on.
- Yeah, this is
an incredible story, please tell it.
- I'll just make it really short you know.
I wake up in the middle of the night,
somebody's trying to break into our house.
I carry my twin girls upstairs,
arm myself with a hammer
because I didn't have
a gun at home.
Hammer, I'm on the phone with the police.
They're trying to force
entry through our front door
and the police are saying, "Be quiet.
"Don't make your presence known,
"we'll be there shortly."
Then my neighbor comes home,
we have a shared walkway,
he scared them off
by turning on the lights so they got away.
30 minutes later I'm giving my testimony,
is that what you say?
- Mm-hm.
- Statement to the police
sitting in my kitchen
and I ask him at the end of the interview,
it's like, "So what can
I do to protect myself
"and my family from this
ever happening again?"
And literally he does
this, "(sighs) Seriously?
"Don't live in this city.
"It is out of control,
we cannot control it."
This was in 2007, you know?
That year I think I believe I paid
about 12 million in taxes and I live
in a fashionable part of town
as I expect a better answer.
- I've been to his penthouse.
It's very nice, yes, yeah.
- Yeah.
- That's where I interviewed you.
(Dave laughs)
- I expect a better answer by the police
than them telling me to leave.
So I wrote an editorial about this
in Sweden's largest conservative newspaper
and told the story about the, basically
what the policeman told
me which is (murmurs)
that this is the really shocking part.
The reaction by the local
newspaper in Malmo was,
they didn't speak to me,
they spoke to the paper
that took my editorial
and said, "This is
completely unacceptable.
"What poor taste and
journalistic unprofessionalism
"that you should publish
an alarmist, populistic
"text like this which
is drawing the attention
"from the people in need.
"This is a wealthy capitalist.
"He's spoiled and you should
not listen to this alarmism."
And that really shocked me
because I had journalists
attacking me on Facebook,
"Why do you write that?
"Why do you put a text
like that out there?"
And this was just when I was
starting my YouTube channel
so this--
- And then you got called
racist and the rest of it, right?
All that stuff.
- Racist, fascist.
- Goes without saying.
- Bigoted.
Right-wing, nut job, you know.
They didn't, they had
to start using--
- White supremacist.
- The word whore.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But so all this being said,
you stayed in Malmo for
two years basically.
- Well he's not Jewish. (laughs)
- Yeah (laughs) right.
(Henrik laughs)
So we'll get to that
(Aron laughs)
in just a second.
But you stayed?
- Yeah, we stayed.
The crime situation has escalated so
when we finally, the straw
that broke the camel's back
was this summer, and I
made a video about this.
It was so tragic because
these drug cartels
are basically fighting it out in Malmo.
They shot a young mother in the head
while she was carrying, and
I can hardly speak about this
because it really upsets me to be honest.
They shot her dead in the head
while she was carrying her newborn baby
because she was affiliated
with one of the drug gangs
and there was a trial thing going on.
This was nine o'clock in the morning
on a public street in one of
the most affluent neighborhoods
in the city and it just
really broke me, honestly.
I am not raising my children in this city
so now we're looking for
a house outside the city.
- So you're on your way out.
As the representative of all
Jewish people in Sweden--
- Please, they would like
that at all.
(Henrik laughs)
- I bet you secretly they would.
Maybe they wouldn't want--
- Who knows, there's--
- neighbors to know.
But there's only what, about 7,000 Jews
left in Sweden, is that right?
- Maybe eight, I don't know.
It fluctuates nowadays.
- Yeah, but can you sort of
explain what's happening?
- But Malmo used to have
a vibrant Jewish community
of around 3,000 Jews.
- My best friend was a Jew.
- For a hundred years and by now
there's probably maybe 300 Jews left.
They've all left Malmo
in the last few yeas.
They go either to
Stockholm if they're young
or if they can to America
or Canada or Israel.
So they've evacuated the city pretty much
and it has gone so far that
two private individuals
donated 40 million of their own money
to the Jewish congregation so that they
can manage security fort
the 300 individuals left
just for the coming 10 years.
- One of them was Dan Olofsson, right?
- That you have interviewed.
- He was on my show.
- I know.
- And I'm hoping to get
him on your show as well.
- Yes, but we will talk
about different subjects.
You talked about entrepreneurship
and I will talk about--
- Oh he's a massive entrepreneur.
- Yeah, he is.
- A super talented guy.
- Well you'd have to
be to donate 20 million
out of your own pocket to found
Sweden's first private militia
which is basically what it will become.
- Can you explain sort of,
so you were talking about
kinda gang violence and that sorta thing.
But can you explain how
that's sort of related
to why Jews would be
getting out specifically?
- Absolutely.
- 'Cause now we're seeing this
sort of all over Europe and--
- No problem at all.
So we've had a huge influx of immigration
from poor Middle Eastern
and North African countries
where state anti-Semitism is part
of everyday life growing up.
So they come to us and
they're still anti-Semites
and the socialists of Sweden,
being on Hitler's side
until the end of the World War
and never dealing with
that have been, you know,
it's a low simmering sort of thing
that they never dealt with.
And they have an alliance
and they don't care if the Jews are
forced out of the city.
That's just, yeah?
- We need to mention
that the government of,
well the Social Democrats
who've been ruling for a long time,
they are actively siding with Palestine
in the Middle Eastern question.
- Yep.
- And you know,
the historical, this goes way back
but it has something to do with
Israel being in cahoots with America
and America's the great Satan so then
because if you're a socialist
being oppressed is a currency.
The Palestinians are the more oppressed
so they side with them.
But we have the youth organization
of the Social Democratic Party,
and I'll send you a video of this
so you can see it for yourself.
When they demonstrate,
like on the 1st of May
they have like a socialist holiday
where they celebrate I don't know,
whatever socialists celebrate.
- Potato day? (laughs)
Whadda socialists celebrate?
- No, we have 1st of May is
International Workers' Day.
They celebrate being poor as well.
(Dave laughs)
(Aron laughs)
- And they--
- Now they will hate me more.
- They sang, and this is on video,
the last time the demonstration--
- They always sing that song.
- Walks through the city.
- It just got caught on tape?
(Henrik sings in foreign language)
- I think you can pick out
a couple words right there.
- Yeah.
- It means, celebrate,
celebrate, celebrate
Palestine and crush Zionism.
And this is the Socialist
Youth Organization people.
These are middle class Swedish people
and to me that's an outrage.
It's an outrage.
They never speak about this.
- No, and the former strong man of Malmo,
the Social Democratic leader Ilmar Reepalu
he had, I mean anti-Semitism.
He has been accused of
being an anti-Semite for
decades now, but he always
denied it and by now
they can't deny it because
there are no Jews left, so.
- Yeah.
- Can you guys explain a little bit
about how the immigration issue arose?
That basically this all
started just in the last
really seven years, something like that.
That a pretty much homogenous society
for better or worse, decided I think
but correct me if I'm wrong,
I think probably with good intentions
by people that weren't thinking that much
to bring in a ton of people.
How many immigrants roughly
have come in over the last--
- Well--
- Half decade or so?
- You can take this one I think.
- If you take it over a decade,
the numbers are always changing
because they're playing around with them
so it depends on how you
kind of calculate it.
But it is a bit over a million people.
- Okay, so roughly a
10th of the population
came in, let's say in the last decade
from these countries.
What do you think the leaders thought
exactly was gonna happen?
Let's say well-intentioned.
But do you think maybe I'm
giving them too much credit?
- No, let's do the well-intentioned
because I like to give people
the benefit of the doubt.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I think they were hoping
for a multi-cultural nirvana
with, you know, kebabs
and some belly dancing
and that everyone else--
- And a lotta smoked fish.
You guys are killin' it
(Henrik laughs)
in the smoked fish game by the way.
- We do have it.
- I ate some
delicious outta that.
- That is true.
- Yeah.
- But other than that, I think the idea
is if you live in a culture
that is so homogenous
as Sweden is, you cannot
think outside the box
of our own culture.
They don't even perceive
that we have a culture.
They probably believe
they will become Swedes
very quickly when they realize
how right a good we are.
- Yes, they will become--
- Turns out didn't happen.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, so if we were not to give them
the benefit of the doubt, because I also,
I try not to go to people's motives
and I think the road to hell is paved
with good intentions and I
think a lot of these people
think they're doing the right thing.
But let's go to the non-good motive part.
(Henrik laughs)
Because I think you just
wrote a book about it.
- Yes.
- I mean, what do you think these people
thought they were doing?
Or whadda you think they thought
was going to happen?
Just when you change
demographics that much,
a 10th of a population is
a huge, huge, huge amount.
- Well I think they wanted to,
so the Social Democrat came into power.
They actually lifted up the working class
to a much better living standard
and the idea was as soon as we get them
up to middle class living standards
they will become true
Communists and understand
that they need to devote
everything to the struggle.
What happened in reality was that they
were perfectly fine with
their flat screen TVs.
They wanted more flat screen
TVs and longer vacation time.
They didn't want to join
a Communist revolution.
They became, in essence,
well our equivalent
of Republicans I suppose.
So they needed new voters in a sense.
And they invoked, and then they took in
a lot of people into
the most over-regulated
labor market in the world and these people
second generation and third
generation immigrants,
they're not getting into the system,
they're keeping them for the ballots.
They want their votes and
they keep them on subsidies
and some of these kids
they see that the system
is rigged against them
and they have no choice.
Of course they will become gangsters
or go off and fight
for ISIS after a while.
Not all of them, obviously.
- I think it's important at this point
to remember that the people that came in,
you know, those individuals
it's not their fault inherently, you know?
- Yeah, they were invited.
- Well that's why I asked
about the intentions
and good or bad, of the
people that brought them in.
Not these people specifically.
- I'd like to think, you
know, crowds always go crazy.
But individuals are much
more reasonable, you know?
And somebody who's fleeing a war,
I have the deepest
sympathy, yes of course.
I would do the same thing.
But it is irresponsible if you have
a so regulated labor market
and you take in more
people than you can help.
That is like you're throwing a party
that goes haywire on Facebook.
Everyone's invited.
(Aron laughs)
But you know, I have drinks for 12 people.
- What did they think
that people were gonna do?
Like what kinda jobs did they think
people were gonna have?
Or did they immediately
say, "You're taken care of
"for a year", you know?
We hear these stories out
of Germany where--
- Well the government
wanted to start a camel
farm in Gothenburg.
- Well that was one experiment for some
and that's a, yeah, that was crazy.
- That actually sounds
like satire, but--
- And sort of racist.
- Yeah.
- But, "No, we can't
"give you a proper job but
we'll give you some subsidies.
"Start a camel farm, you
should be good at that.
"And also, we have plenty
of camels in Sweden."
No we don't.
We have reindeer.
- So truly, people come in
and as you said they're often fleeing war.
You have sympathies with all these people.
The government then
says, "Here's some stuff.
"But you can't have it forever" although
they sort of do have it forever.
But not just the, "Can't have it forever"
it's a limited amount of stuff, right?
"We can't put you" and
then they can turn around
and say, "See, we're also racist
"'cause we didn't make you
millionaires at night one"
and the rest of it.
- Exactly.
They get a flat,
they get a minimum living--
- Subsidy.
- And then they are expected to vote left
and that is what it looks like.
If you break down the statistics
of different municipalities
and how they vote.
I mean in the (speaks in
foreign language) in Malmo
was like 70 to 90% voted
for the Social Democrat
of the lefts.
- Yes, yes.
I mean, you know, we have
the numbers for all of that.
But what's happened is tragically
we have created a tremendous segregation.
- Yeah.
- A new under class
if you will, an immigrant under class,
which Sweden never had.
And we don't know how to deal with it
and we're also running out of money
because we have the most
expensive welfare system
in the world and now we're
trying to deal with it.
Nobody knows what to do.
- This is a sort of
dangerous question in a way
but I think these conversations
always end up here
which is, do you think in a weird way
this then breeds racism?
- Yes.
- That good-intentioned people, right,
I mean you just made it very clear.
You have no ill-will towards these people.
But then these people
come into these countries,
they're given these things.
They demand more, the
politicians use them for votes.
And then good people who are not racist
but maybe don't have a lotta time
to think about all these things
suddenly start becoming kind of racist.
It's just a sad fact of humanity.
- Absolutely, and I
think it goes both ways.
I think the Swedes wanted
to invite poor people
from the Third World to
come and live in Sweden
because they wanted to
feel good themselves.
But also they thought,
"Everyone would want
"to become Swedish, of course."
But then they get a lot of immigrants
and the immigrants look
at the Swedish society
and they're like, "Eh,
maybe I'm gonna keep
"some of my own culture", yeah?
"'Cause I don't think this is so great."
- And if you were to sort of--
- And also, if you keep
them out of the system
and you never left them in
and you stick them in ghettos,
of course they will start to hate you.
- And there's a weird thing
that I think Europe has
that I think America doesn't have
which is that if you were
to assimilate them more,
sort of push more of a
Swedish culture on them
that would be against Swedish
nature in a bizarre way.
Where America, we have a melting pot here
so come here with all of your traditions
and all of those things, but
mix into the fabric of America.
Where Europe has more of a
ghettoization of culture.
- This I think, the reason
America can do this better
is because your country is
founded on the principle
of individuality and individuals.
Whereas Sweden is founded
on the idea of collectivism
and that makes it really
hard to break the mold.
Now I have a good friend,
he's doing a lotta work
with newly arrived African boys
and the top question,
this is Mustafa Panshiri,
the question he's most
often asked by these guys
is like, "How do I make Swedish friends?
"I don't know, they never open up,
"I'm never in touch with them."
And at the same time, this is again,
bringing tears to my eyes.
They want to work.
They want to break into becoming useful.
At the same time Swedes
will be telling you,
"Oh no, how you should behave?
"No, I couldn't possibly tell you
"just be yourself."
- Yeah, yes.
- They give nothing away
because they don't understand
being so collectivist.
We have a very closed,
very complicated culture
and if we want to invite
people into our culture
we need to start, you know,
"Here we do it this way.
"This is" you know, but that
is considered almost racist.
Certainly socially
aggressive to tell people
that, "Well this is how
we do things around here."
- We take off our shoes before
we come into someone's home.
That is quite unique.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it's us and the Japanese.
Although we're more sloppy
than the Japanese I think.
(Dave laughs)
- And because this
culture of--
- But there are all
these unwritten rules,
of course there are.
But for the longest
time Swedes denied that
because it would be racist to admit
we had our own culture.
- Can you guys talk a little bit
about how you differentiate from
some of the other Nordic countries?
Because as I said, we always
point to the Nordic countries
but Sweden is the one
that we really focus on.
But it sounds from what I can tell,
and I did visit Denmark
and I visited Finland
and a couple other places,
Denmark doesn't seem to have the problems
as much as you guys.
- Well they did up until they
had those cartoonist scandals
and then they sort of understood
what it was all about.
If you can't criticize
Mohammed that's basically
blasphemy laws and no modern Western state
would stand for that.
- I've had Flemming Rose
on who obviously you know
is the publisher of the cartoons.
And what an absolute brave person
and someone who now has
to live unfortunately
with a lifetime of security,
who the idea that this
is a racist or a bigot
is so patently absurd.
- Yes.
- It was a Muslim author who was trying
to find a cartoonist that
sparked the whole idea
in the first place.
- Yeah, I know.
- And he was trying to help, I mean it's--
- But I also think culturally
over hundreds of years,
Sweden and Denmark they've
fought for supremacy
in Scandinavia and they sort of culturally
define themselves in
opposition to each other.
So Danes are more, they're
closer to the continent.
They're more vivacious.
They like to call a shovel a shovel,
actually in Danish it's a spade a spade.
But that would be wrong here I think.
And Sweden is completely the
opposite, don't rock the boat.
- Well if you look at this
from a historical perspective
I think it's fair to say that Sweden
was the Nordic super power in the 1600s.
- Yes.
- We'd basically taken over
the rest of the Scandinavian countries
and then we kind of gradually
lost control of that.
We gave Norway independence
and Denmark broke off.
But the languages and the
culture is fairly similar.
But Sweden's attitude has though remained
as the stuck up big brother
that always knows best.
I mean, we are a very arrogant culture
if I can say so myself.
I think it's pretty clear
that the Danes for instance,
they think we're stuck up
and we're just plain wrong
and now that we are, you know,
we've gone a bad way it's--
- By now proven wrong.
- Right, right.
- It is so embarrassing to admit it.
So now it's like a situation where
"No, I have to maintain
that I'm doing it this way
"because it's too embarrassing to come out
"to say, 'Okay, that was a
big mistake, I'm sorry.'"
You know, the Danes are
putting up border controls
against Sweden now because,
- Yeah, towards us.
- "We don't want the problems you have
"with bombs to be
exported into Copenhagen."
- Right, but if you talk
about those problems
- Exactly.
- Is there a lotta trouble?
- No, the response when Denmark did that,
the response from Swedish politicians
was like, "Oh this is completely alarmist
"but we welcome the Danes
to do what they please."
So they were just saving face.
- Yeah.
- But it's, I mean for Sweden
which is one of the most
advanced IT service countries
in the world, to have
to deal with the fact
that people are saying, "We have to have
"border (chuckles) controls
to you guys because there's
"so much craziness
spilling into our country."
- This analogy that you
mentioned of sort of
a Hollywood facade on all this.
As I said, it looks too
good on the outside,
I really do think is part of the problem.
It looks too good from the outside.
Everyone looks too good
and everyone's clothes
look too neat and new
and pressed and great
and everyone looks sort of too healthy.
And I guess that's not
(Henrik laughs)
in every city, but it's
at least what's exported.
- When we have a far
reaching eugenic programs
that took care of that.
(Henrik chuckles)
- That's probably a whole other show.
- That's when you get guys like this.
Look at the perfection.
(Dave laughs)
- Is there anything else
that we didn't hit on
sort of real meat of all of this?
- Has it been an hour already?
- It's basically been an hour, yeah.
- I'm sorry, it's because
he talks all the time.
- It's a lotta talk.
- But I've been here before
so it's fine.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- No, I think we're
fine for now, aren't we?
- Yeah.
- Or was it anything else
you wanted to--
- No, I was asking you guys
because--
- No, I think it was great.
- This was as much of a recap of,
well I guess we should talk a little bit
about Ikea or some of your
other (laughs) whatever--
- We can talk about he ordered
a drink the other night
when we were to dinner
(Dave laughs)
and they made him put it together himself.
As revenge for all the
Ikea furniture they bought.
- You ordered a what?
Like an Irish coffee or something?
- I wanted an Irish coffee for dessert.
- Yeah.
- And it came in parts.
- You know?
I got a cup of coffee
and what's in it now, whiskey or cognac?
Baileys, three separate
glasses so I had to build it
and you know--
- I could tell
the serving staff they were getting even.
- And we were lacking the cream.
So just like in Ikea, always you know,
one missing piece.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But you did have your
Allen wrench with you
and you were able to put it
(Henrik laughs)
together very quickly.
- We made it work.
- It was very impressive.
I do have a lot of Ikea here.
I'll give you a tour of my Ikea.
You know that in L.A. we have
the world's biggest Ikea.
Did you know that?
- No I did not.
- It is in Burbank.
Maybe we may have to go
there this afternoon.
(Aron sighs)
(Henrik laughs)
The world's biggest Ikea.
If I went with two Swedes
(Henrik laughs)
and had Swedish meatballs.
- Oh they wouldn't give you
the royal treatment,
trust me.
- No, nothing?
- No, nothing.
- They probably, well
with you two I'd probably be--
- We'd be kicked out.
We'd be kicked out.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Something like that.
- It has been a pleasure
chatting with you guys.
You know what?
Because you are professional
podcast, YouTube hosts
I'm gonna let you guys pimp
yourselves out directly
to camera, Henrik, right over there.
- Thank you Dave.
- Yeah.
- Well if you are interested
in Europe in general,
Sweden specifically, you
can check out my channel
where I do weekly commentaries
on current issues.
I do analysis on economic,
business, finance,
that sort of thing, with
a European eye on it.
I also do stuff to explain this
for an English-speaking audience.
I'm really a businessman
so this more of a vocation
than a profession for me.
But I think it would be interesting
for me to find an
English-speaking audience.
- What's the name of your YouTube channel?
- My YouTube channel if you put in HenrikJ
you will find my English-speaking channel.
And from there you can
kind of find my Swedish one
if you want more content.
It's all subtitled in
English so you can see it.
But then you really have
to be a sort of Sweden nerd
if you wanna go into
Swedish interior politics.
- (laughs) He is a pro, so
I really set you up here.
- He is absolutely, yeah I know.
- Look into the camera
Aron Flam.
- Oh my god. (sighs)
My name is Aron Flam.
I'm a Swedish comedian and podcaster.
The name of my podcast is
"Deconstructed Criticism".
I have a few episodes in English.
I've just finished a book that I wrote
and published myself in Sweden
about the situation the Western world
finds itself in today because
of what happened in the past.
There will be an English
translation on my webpage,
aronflam.com soon enough, thank you.
- Well gentlemen, I
consider us colleagues now.
- We are.
- In the world that we
exist in, but more importantly
I consider us friends.
We had a great time the other night
and I know this is just the beginning
of things we'll do together.
- Yes.
- Follow these guys
on Twitter and on YouTube
and all those good places
and get over to Sweden and visit them.
You'll take people out Henrik?
- Oh yeah, I take good care
of my guests, don't I?
(Dave laughs)
- Yes.
- All right, thanks everybody.
If you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about international issues
instead of non-stop yelling,
check out our international playlist.
And if you wanna watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, check out
our full episode playlist.
They're all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.